- There's been so much stress and anxiety
and negativity around this election
and I think it's having
a real impact on me
and my emotional well-being.
So I just wanna take that
energy, that negativity,
and turn it into something positive
and go out there and do
something useful with my time.
(soft piano music)
- This weekend, we are going to go canvas
in Nevada for Hillary Rodham Clinton.
This election has been crazy
and I feel a lot of fear.
One of the ways that I can
feel better about what happens
on Tuesday is knowing that
this weekend I made an effort
to help get out the vote.
- This campaign was weird
because young people
and people my age were less
politically active than usual
and I feel like I sort of
subscribed to that as well,
but as we get closer and
closer to the reality
that Donald Trump might become president
I am definitely feeling more
of an urge to get involved.
- When I graduated college I
became a community organizer
and now it's crunch time.
- My expectations for
tomorrow are to be very tired
and very frustrated.
- It's a swing state,
so they've been getting a
lot of people calling them,
a lot of people knocking on their doors.
- We're gonna drive four
hours, we're gonna talk
to a lot of people who
will probably yell at us,
and then we're gonna drive
four hours back to LA.
- So let's go, let's do it!
- Nevada, here we come.
- So, I'm awake and the
sun is not even up yet.
- I really don't want to go,
I just wanna go back to bed.
- HRC,
fully repping.
- I'm secretly hoping
that nobody shows up.
- Gonna go save America,
gonna go do our duty.
We're on the road, going.
- Getting excited.
- Woo, go Hillary!
- We're here in the office in Nevada.
- Someone has made an
amazing mural behind me.
This office is dope.
- And I even met Hillary Clinton.
She's happy 'cause she
knows she's gonna win.
We just got our packets and
we're gonna head out to canvas.
I'm a little nervous.
We'll be talking to democrats
and just convincing
people to get out to vote.
- Already with her, with her, with her.
- We're at a house right now
where we just got trained
by someone who walked us through
what we're supposed to say.
It's very overwhelming,
we just heard it once
and now we just go out
and say it to people.
- We just got our walk packets.
The organizer in me is already
(bang drowns out speaker)
how to tear them up, make
it the most efficient.
- Okay, well, we're in
the suburbs of Las Vegas
and we're about to start.
I feel like once I get
a couple houses down,
I'll get the rhythm of it, but
right now, yeah, it's scary.
- We just knocked out our first street.
I talked to one person who was like,
"Yeah, I'm definitely a Republican."
On to the next street.
- I'm feeling pretty
bad because I just went
to five or six houses
and no one was there.
Someone sort of made fun of me.
Sort of made me feel like,
man, we drove all the way here.
Is this a good use of our time?
- Just knocked on the door of someone who
is having a baby shower.
I was standing at the door
and I was hearing them clap
and cheer and I just couldn't do it.
So I chickened out and
now I'm regretting it
because there were so many conversations
to be had about voting.
- Just talked to somebody
who was a Hillary supporter
and said she was gonna go vote on Tuesday.
She knew where she was voting.
She was really enthusiastic
and supportive of us,
so that felt really good.
- Just had an amazing conversation
with a very sweet lady named Maria.
Got through the whole script with her.
She was like, "Yes I am voting."
I was like, "Great.
"Do you know where your polling place is?
"How are you gonna get to the polls?
"Do you know what time you're going?"
She's got a voting plan.
- We're probably about 10 houses deep
and I'm actually having fun.
Every house is a new adventure.
- I am crying human tears.
I just talked to a lady
who definitely was not
in the place where she wanted
to talk about anything,
and especially not with
a stranger who was coming
to talk to her about an election
she is pissed off about.
By the end of the conversation
she was so just more open.
We talked about how important Nevada is,
how much her voice counts here,
and left that experience just
feeling humbled and emotional.
Glad that I was able to have
such a meaningful conversation
with someone today.
- We've been walking for three hours now
and my legs are so fucking tired.
My whole body is exhausted,
but it feels good.
I wanna keep going.
I just talked to somebody who
said she was going to vote
but she didn't know who yet.
We had a little bit of a conversation.
I'm not sure if she wanted to be swayed.
I'm not sure if I did sway her,
but hopefully she'll
think about her decision.
- [Alaina] This is the polling place
that we've been talking about.
A convenient walk away.
Look how freakin' beautiful it is.
- Nevada is so tight right now.
Hillary Clinton's at
49% and Trump is at 50.
So I feel like we are making a difference
and our presence here matters.
It was worth getting
out of bed this morning.
- Even if people aren't on your list
you're kind of interacting with them.
There's like all these
kids around right now
and they're very interested like,
"What are you doing, what are you doing?"
and I was like, "Yeah, I'm
just a neighbor coming around
"to make sure all your
parents are ready to vote.
"Can you talk to them for me?
"Make sure they are."
And this one girl was like,
"Yeah, Hillary Clinton!"
- It's funny because out here you realize
that you're like a face of the campaign
and you really do wanna
be nice to everybody
and even people who disagree with you.
- There was a bunch of
people just sitting around
in a driveway.
I could hear them as I was
walking away being like,
"Did you vote yet?"
And just knowing that my presence
is stimulating those
conversations is super cool.
- This process is just
making it so clear to me
how personal this is and
how every vote does matter.
I just knocked on the door
and it was this Latina woman
and she said she's been watching
the election on the news
and she can't take it anymore
and she doesn't wanna vote,
and it was really upsetting that someone
who normally would vote democratic
just didn't wanna vote at all.
We tried talking to her and
she became sort of interested.
She was like, "What times
do the polls close?"
Maybe she'll go out.
But it was heartbreaking
because as we were saying,
"This is a swing state,
your vote really matters"
her daughter was shouting,
"Hillary Clinton!
"Hillary Clinton!"
And I wanted to be like,
"Listen to your daughter.
"She wants to see Hillary
Clinton in the White House.
"She wants to see a woman
in the White House."
I really hope that woman votes.
I thought everyone would be mean to me.
A couple people were mean to me,
but so many people just wanna talk to you
and wanna discuss issues with you.
It's been really heartening.
- It's getting pretty dark out.
- At the beginning of the
night I was so nervous
and at this point I just wanna keep going.
I feel fearless ringing on doors.
I could talk to a million people tonight.
Had this amazing
conversation with this woman
who was very excited to vote,
very excited about Hillary,
and then I met her husband
who was similarly excited about Hillary
but he was a felon and he couldn't vote.
He was very informed, he knew
who he wanted to vote for.
Then it was really hard to see
that he couldn't exercise
his right that he had.
- Just had an awesome
conversation with a lady
who recently moved to this house.
She's not registered here,
she's registered at her last location,
so we made sure that she was heading
to her old polling location.
Just making sure those
logistics were in place.
- Overall, it's been a
really worthwhile experience
and it makes me wanna get involved more.
I wanna do phone banking,
make sure everyone gets out to vote.
- We're wrapping up just
a couple more houses.
Really tired, ready to go
home, but let's finish this up.
- I was so tired when I
got back I just collapsed
into my bed and I felt
so happy to have gone.
It was like a 180 from
how I felt that morning.
There were some conversations
where I really did feel
that their opinions had
changed a little bit.
They were more likely to
get out there and vote,
and that's so cool and powerful.
- I'm so glad we went.
It has been an election
where a lot of us have felt helpless,
and I forgot that being active
makes you feel so much more involved
and able to do something.
- I definitely feel a different sort
of investment when I
look at these numbers.
I feel that I can do
something to change them.
We have to do better, we can do better,
and I feel the sense of
wanting to participate.
- There isn't anything
that replaces that feeling
of making a difference in your community.
- Showing up at someone's
door and being able to listen
to what's affecting their
lives is really important
to the political process
and really important
to my life as a person
who lives in this country
and wants to improve the country.
- There is nothing I would've rather done
the weekend before the election
than knock doors in a swing state.